civilians not soldiers have to rise to
this challenge armed with tools not
tanks
but it's still a front line of sorts as
Ukraine battles to stop Russia from
knocking the power out permanently this
winter
Russia's missile strikes against the
power infrastructure make this already
perilous work even more high risk
four people from vassell's company have
been killed on duty since the War Began
foreign
by targeting the energy grid and trying
to switch off the power Vladimir Putin
is creating a new front line in people's
homes it means the efforts of workers
like these to fix the damage and keep up
with routine repairs are so crucial in
this fight for survival
this is part of the power grid that was
hit during one of several waves of
airstrikes since October
Russia's aim seems to be to try to
freeze ukrainians into submission
but the boss of a main energy provider
says his workers are quick to repair the
damage
so I have strong belief that there is no
chance that a complete blackout can
continue for for a long time so that
people cannot live
families as well are learning to adapt
to Rolling blackouts as Ukraine rations
what power it still has
today
[Music]
lubov and her husband are also stocking
up on food grown in their own back
Garden
the ability to fend for yourself could
become key
and this couple say they'll never give
in Japan
um
so much uncertainty here
the only thing Ukraine knows for sure is
that this will be a particularly long
dark cold winter
debraham Sky News Kiev